this week lenovo
bought motorola
from google for 2.91 billion dollars now
in case you forgot google just finished
buying motorola mobility in 2012 for 12
billion dollars this is something that
needs explaining
[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here now as
disclosure a lot of the details of this
deal are private and i'm not going to
disclose anything that's supposed to be
private obviously but i have been in
contact with motorola as a lot of you
guys know and i'll continue to stay in
touch with them but right now with all
the details that we have this is
everything you need to know about
motorola being purchased from google by
lenovo now since there were three major
players in this deal itself there are
three perspectives to be able to see
this from from lenovo's perspective from
motorola's perspective and from google's
perspective from the lenovo perspective
this is an investment to dive head first
into the smartphone market in the united
states uh and to be honest this was
basically a steal for them at 2.9
billion dollars they could have done a
lot worse plus they've been on a bit of
a spending sphere recently anyway after
buying ibm servers but the idea here is
when you think of lenovo what do you
think of you think of the pc
manufacturer because that's what they do
they make think pads their main
competitors being dell and hp what you
don't think of when you think of lenovo
is smartphones in the united states
because that's just not what they do
here fun fact though lenovo is number
five in the count of total smartphones
shipped in the fourth quarter of 2013
worldwide they have a killer
international presence they're one of
the biggest smartphone sellers in the
world
so obviously since the pc market isn't
exactly exploding they figured they'd
focus on mobile and what better way to
do that than to buy up a company in the
united states and get a huge kickstart
on entering the us smartphone business
instead of starting from scratch lenovo
by buying motorola gets all of
motorola's relationships with us
carriers all their product designers and
their development team and motorola's
reputation they get all that in a bundle
that's what we like to call brand equity
and if lenovo is smart they'll keep that
they'll keep the motorola name up front
and continue operations just the way
they were business as usual just with
lenovo pulling strings behind the scenes
lenovo's hoping that moves like this
will in five years or so make them
number one in the united states
it's possible you know i you know the
number one thing i'm worried about here
with lenovo is that if you look at all
the other designs of their phones they
are really
bland and obviously they're all
mid-range to low-end phones for the most
part but i'm not very excited about
lenovo phone designs from what i've seen
and i don't even know if those will do
well in the united states so what i'm
hoping is they definitely keep those
motorola designers on board who are
helping around with the moto g and moto
x and get them
very into the talks of the next motorola
smartphone the motorola perspective is
really not all that interesting you know
a deal is a deal they're kind of being
tugged back and forth right now but like
i said if lenovo is smart and if they
continue with that motorola branding and
they leave the motorola name up front
they shouldn't have any problems and
they should let motorola operate like
business as usual that's what they were
doing underneath google a lot of people
think that they were working like this
with google they were kind of working
with google behind the scenes and lenovo
needs to be that behind the scenes again
even if they want their name on
everything and then there's the google
perspective which is a lot more
interesting because it's actually about
more than just motorola so when google
first bought motorola mobility for 12
billion dollars back in 2012 there's a
lot of speculation about why did they do
this are they going to make a phone
together is the next nexus gonna be a
motorola phone those were serious uh
questions that people had so basically
to clear it all up uh for the financial
purchase google made a blog post on
their site and it's actually still there
i'll have it linked below the like
button where they gave the reasons and
the benefits for buying motorola and
those two main reasons were they might
make some phones together work together
a little bit
and motorola's patent portfolio with the
motorola acquisition google picked up
more than 15 000 patents to protect
android
now of course after this acquisition a
lot of us are still asking the question
like moto nexus is that happening or not
how closely is google working with
motorola now check out this clip from
the interview i had with the ceo of
motorola literally about two months ago
so back to just a whole motorola thing
uh as you guys as google and motorola
work together i have no idea how closely
or far apart they're working so what are
like google and motorola working on
together because moto x was a pretty
awesome collaboration in the first place
well no moto x was all motorola i mean
so motorola is we're owned by google so
we have um financial support from google
but we operate completely independently
and and and google has been pretty clear
that it wants to preserve that
independence because android is an open
source platform and it's important for
uh any partner who wants to build a
product based on android to be treated
the same way so if you're samsung or
sony or htc and you hear that you know
sure you could take his word for it but
honestly ever since that acquisition it
seemed like to a lot of people and a lot
of vendors that now motorola was the
favorite oem motorola got first dibs
motorola was the favorite of google who
was making android and that made a lot
of them uncomfortable and a lot of them
like samsung made moves away from
android and started to prepare
themselves otherwise you can see a lot
of this in samsung's touchwiz and their
new magazine ui but yes google did
believe it or not keep up a firewall
between them and motorola then lenovo
came along with their ambitions and they
said hey can we buy that from you and
they said sure but they sold away parts
of motorola not all of it they kept that
massive patent portfolio and they also
kept under the android division the
advanced technology and projects
part which was responsible for project
aura the modular smartphone concept so
they kept a lot of cool stuff and
they'll continue to work with that the
rest of motorola mobility was sold for
2.91 billion still pretty low still a
steal for lenovo but obviously a great
acquisition so if my math is right
google gave lenovo a hell of a deal and
also values those thousands of patents a
lot like at billions of dollars try
suing us now apple like that's some
serious patent protection right there i
should also note that google also bought
nest for three billion dollars nest is
the makers of those beautiful smart
thermostats and smoke detectors and
things like that and they also already
also seem to be integrating with google
way more than motorola ever did so they
seem to be much more of a hardware
partner so i'm actually excited to see
what they do together so the number one
question we're seeing now is what is
going to happen to current motorola
devices like the moto x and the moto g
just a couple of weeks ago i was at ces
talking with rick osterlow who was the
vice president at motorola who was
showing me you know really proud of all
the updates they're rolling out with and
he was showing out the new
wood back for the moto x that was going
to be available soon does that all just
stop well again if lenovo is smart they
won't touch a thing they'll let it
continue business operations as usual
and then slowly take advantage of
motorola's resources and relationships
later so i'll say right now this doesn't
affect the day-to-day stuff that
motorola is doing with moto x and moto g
but again the thing about these things
is these deals they take a while they're
large financial transactions they take a
while to go through
so i'll keep in touch with them and if i
hear any updates i will let you guys
know on twitter if you guys want to
follow at mkbhd you will definitely hear
the first of that now you might have
also heard that google and samsung have
been in these talks and that they might
have something to do with the sale so
the end result of this is that google's
selling motorola to stop competing with
samsung and others and samsung is asked
by google to stop altering and screwing
with android so much uh and even if that
wasn't the original intention of the
deal it still has that effect ever you
know ever since google bought motorola
there was always that awkwardness about
the other manufacturers because like i
said it felt like motorola was the
favored one so now that google has sold
motorola there is no favored one
google's not competing anymore you know
they're not part of motorola now it's an
open even playing field and they asked
that samsung dial it back a bit and let
google control android a bit more in
return so google's making moves and you
know i understand it may be kind of sad
to see google and motorola split because
it seemed like right when motorola
started working with google they started
doing really great things they were on a
roll with the moto x a great phone and a
moto g a really inexpensive value phone
but you got to remember that it's been
reiterated by motorola people over and
over again that that was all motorola
and that they will continue to do
awesome stuff like that even without
google's financial backing because
they're in a different mindset
altogether even if they're under lenovo
now instead of google so to summarize
google
buys motorola for the patents
supercharges them a little bit and then
lets them go and lenovo comes in and
buys them and hopes to keep the momentum
going
and try to make some money off of it
we'll see how that goes samsung on the
other hand was asked by google to tone
down with the touchwiz customizations we
will stop competing we've sold motorola
the playing field is even we just want
to control android so this has been
mkbhd thank you for watching guys and i
hope you continue to watch because i
will have my eye on all three of these
companies
for 2014. thank you for watching and
i'll talk to you guys in the next one
peace
[Music]
do
[Music]